visite du chef de l'État il est en
déplacement dans une maison de santé à
Vendôme une visite sous-trait haute
sécurité et avec quelques casseroles
tous ont été tenus à bonne distance
interdiction de pénétrer dans un
périmètre de protection avec un
dispositif sonore amplificateur de son
selon un arrêté préfectoral président de
la République les Français en attente
beaucoup c'est lui qu'ils ont élu ils
ont pas élu le Premier ministre où les
ministres et donc en disant j'aurais dû
mouiller ma chemise un peu plus ça
démontre la faiblesse de son
gouvernement dialoguer aller au contact
c'est ce que demandent Emmanuel Macron
dans une lettre adressée à ses troupes
un an après sa réélection rien ne serait
pire que de déserter le terrain dans les
semaines qui viennent comme moi vous
allez à nouveau sillonner le pays en
nous chanterons
le temps des casseroles au gouvernement
qui donne la rougeole
feront tous la tête
ils sont accueillis par des casseroles
apostropher lors de cérémonies et même
bloqué dans un train depuis la
promulgation de la réforme des retraites
à chacun de leurs déplacements les
ministres auront la peur sortir
il est casseroles seront des banderoles
on a l'impression qu'il fait là
aujourd'hui l'explication de la réforme
qu'il aurait dû faire avance à temps le
président est sur le terrain et je
préfère mille fois puisque vous avez
repris ce terme tout à l'heure je
préfère mille fois en prise en charge
utile plutôt qu'un président planqué et
puis hier c'est
le ministre fortement perturbé et
remanié et surprise à son retour à Paris
un cortège de manifestants la tendaye ou
empêché de descendre du TGV comme hier
dans la Sarthe pour le garde des sceaux
Eric Dupond-Moretti tout cela est
évidemment condamnable et je vais
continuer évidemment à me déplacer de
façon régulière parce que je suis un
ministre de terrain qui est des
militants syndicaux politiques d'ultra
gauche qui nous attendent quand on vient
se déplacer qui passe 4 heures devant un
lieu où on se déplace en pleine journée
en pleine semaine
écoutez on n'a pas la vraie France
pour écouter les Français et pour
entendre les Français les gens qui
manifestent aujourd'hui leur opposition
ils s'amusent pas ils auraient mieux à
faire que d'aller à l'endroit où le
ministre vient pour s'en déplacement
mais bien évidemment que c'est une
France qui bosse il y a les casseroles
et puis il y a ceux qui les tiennent et
ceux qui le tiennent c'est ceux qui font
tourner le pays j'ai du mal et je pense
que beaucoup de Français ont du mal
également à croire qu'il puisse faire en
trois mois donc en 100 jours ce qu'il a
été incapable de faire
36 ans à peine lancée déjà suspendu
l'opération wambushua Mayotte et sur
peau jusqu'à nouvel ordre la justice a
suspendu dans la nuit et la démolition
d'un bidonville dans le quartier de
talus II Magic à vous car impossible de
détruire ses abris sans fragiliser
d'autres habitations l'action menée à
Mayotte et la restauration de la paix
républicaine c'est une action difficile
mais extrêmement résolue le préfet fait
appel de cette décision
signe de l'attention sur place dans une
interview à nos confrères de Mayotte la
première je refuse d'ailleurs qu'on
emploie ces termes-là jeunes ou gamins
c'est délinquant ces voyous ces
terroristes il faut un moment donné il
faut peut-être un tuyau je pèse mes mots
je pense que c'est inacceptable mais ça
reflète la le l'exaspération et en fait
la nécessité de cette opération hier les
autorités comoriennes ont refusé
l'accostage de ce navire qui
transportait notamment des migrants
expulsés de Mayotte
il a dû faire demi-tour les Comores
évoquant des travaux sur le port aux
États-Unis Joe Biden et candidat s'a
réélection en 2024 s'est confirmé il l'a
annoncé lui-même il y a quelques minutes
sur les réseaux sociaux Kev Adams se
défend après la diffusion d'une enquête
de Mediapart sur le film d'animation
push l'humoriste d'y avoir seulement
fait la promotion de ce projet
participatif comme d'autres célébrités
en 2022 il a proposé à ses abonnés
d'acheter des NFC en forme d'ourson
virtuel à 1250 euros l'unité à la
disparition de François Léotard à l'âge
de 81 ans l'ancien patron de l'UDF avait
été ministre de la Culture entre 1986 et
1988 puis ministre de la Défense
d'Edouard Balladur ça va lui valoir des
ennuis et judiciaires et pas des
moindres la faire Karachi ça vient de là
François Léotard il sera condamné dans
le volet financier de cette affaire
Karachi à deux ans de prison avec sursis
et a eu une amende plus de 500
internautes qui ont cru et ont investi
un million et demi d'euros mais depuis
aucune nouvelle le projet est à l'arrêt
aujourd'hui plusieurs investisseurs
envisagent des actions en justice